complex regional pain syndrome or
crp s
formerly known as
reflex sympathetic dystrophy or rst
is a chronic condition that
causes persistent burning pain
and swelling in the arms, hands,
legs, or feet the normal response  from your
body to an injury begins when
pain receptors transmit
pain messages in the form of nerve impulses
to the brain once these impulses
reach the pain centers in the
brain they generate new
impulses and send them through the
nervous system  sympathetic to the site
of injury sympathetic input
triggers an inflammatory response
that causes blood
vessels to expand the inflammatory response
also leads to swelling and
redness in the damaged tissue
as your wound heals the
swelling and redness subside
and  the pain goes away however if
you suffer from regional pain syndrome
In complex nal pain and
swelling does not go away after
the wound has healed and may
worsen over
time although the exact cause is
unknown one theory suggests
that after the injury has healed
abnormal impulses continue to
travel along the nerves to  your skin
and blood vessels stimulating the
inflammatory response there are two types
of complex regional pain syndrome
although the symptoms are the same for
both if you have mds c1 your
condition may be caused
by disease or injury but you do not
have an injury  of the nerve in the
affected area if you suffer from cr ps2 your
condition is clearly related to
a nerve injury in the affected area
the treatment of
complex regional pain syndrome focuses on the
treatment of pain since there is no cure
for this condition the options
treatment may include medication
physical therapy nerve block
implantation of a device
pain control surgery and psychosocial support